يبدو ان الدول المشاركه في كاس العالم
2022 9 جاهده لظهور بشكل متميز على صعيد
الترجيع حيث تعمل عده بلدان مشاركه في
العرس العالمي لمنع المشجعين المتعصبين من
الوصول الى قطر المستضيفه للممتعه
الارجنتين وبريطانيا كانت على راس الدول
في منع المشجعين المتورطين في اعمال عن في
بلادهم من حضور كاس العالم اعلنت الجهات
الامنيه في ميونخ
من الذهاب لقطر مؤكده انها تريد اعاده
السلام لكره القدم في بريطانيا
دول خطر ممنوعين من الذهاب لحضور مباريات
كاس العالم حيث اكدت سلطات البريطانيه
وانها لن تسمح بتشويه البطوله العالميه
[موسيقى]
بما انها تحدث عن المشاغبين في كره القدم
وفي المونديال تحديدا كيف تراهم بوجهه
نظرك كخبير في الشان الرياضي عرفناه اليوم
وهي قضيه عاليه جدا والحل الوحيد
للفيفا كان يعني وقفت خاص قرارات وبمنع
المشجعين للمشاغبين من حضور المباراه
الجميع يتذكر طبعا ما فعلت جماهير
الارجنتين بدءا من بدايه البطوله في عام
1930 من قرن الماضي يعني بعدها ان خسر
المباراه النهائيه قاموا بتحطيم مبنى
السفاره الجوانيه في بونيس اريس طبعا في
حتى في الظلم المشجعين الخطرين يطال ايضا
سفارات بلادها ايطالي اتحاد كره القدم في
بلادها في حال لمئه اهل المنتخبها نحو
المونديال كما حدث في 38 حتى في 86 عندما
فازت الارجنتين بقلقب كاس العالم لم يخرج
دون مشاكل وقاموا باصطياد المشجعين
الانجليزي وتكسير وتحطيم الكثير يعني هي
موجه كبيره تشتاح ملاعب كره القدم افتح
الاجواء المحبه وكره القدم يعني الفيفا هي
رياضه السلام رقم واحد لكن من دون
المشاحنات لا يمكن ان تشاهدي او تتابعي
مباراه لكره القدم
فيما يتعلق بالرياضه التعصب الكروي في هذا
الحديث راح نحكي مع المحل الرياضي محمود
ماهر الذي انضم الينا الان استاذ محمود
يسعد هالصباح قرار جريء اليوم انه نحكي عن
دول عاشقه لكره القدم والنوت حد من
الجمهور والحضور الى المونديال بسبب هذا
التعصب ما رايك بهذا القرار اولا
طبعا قرار
رائع جدا من الدول زي انجلترا وزي
قطر كمان انها تكون متعاونه مع بريطانيا
ومع الارجنتين مع جميع الدول المشاركه في
كاس العالم لانه هناك يعني جماهير متعصبه
جدا في في كاس العالم بصفه مستمره من
ضمنها مثلا جماهير بولندا يعني من زمان
حتى استاذ عبد الجواد وهو بيتكلم من من
السبعينات او من الستينات بدات لما ظهرت
اكثر في كاس العالم على وجه التحديد همم
الدول المنظمه لكاس العالم بتدعو ان لبعض
المنتخبات لا تتاهل لكاس العالم
وجود همم يعني
البلاد زي همم انجلترا زي همم بولندا
الارجنتين
وتكلمته كثير عن الارجنتين ان هم منعوا
3000 مشجع
ودي مش اول مره تحصل لان هم يمنعوا مشجعين
حصلت قبل كده في مونديال روسيا همم منع
مشجعين من انجلترا ومشجعين من بولندا
ومشجعين من الارجنتين عدد كبير جدا حتى في
كاس العالم في جنوب افريقيا اتمنع نفس
العدد تقريبا مرحبا محمود بدي اسالك سؤال
وجوابه جدا يكون صريح رغم كل القوانين
التي تمنع دخول المشجعين القاطرين
المشجعين بلاقوا طريقه وبيلتفوا حول هذا
القانون وبيدخلوا الدول وبيحضروا
المباريات وبيكونوا بجانب الملعب صحيح ولا
لا صحيح صحيح
بيلاقوا حلول لانه بيتم منع الجماهير قبل
10 ايام من مونديال بيسحب يعني بيتم ايقاف
الباسوردات من قبل المونديال 10 دقائق 10
ايام لكن الجماهير ممكن تخرج قبل ال 10
ايام من الد- من البلد في انجلترا مثلا
ممكن يخرجوا ويحضروا عن طريق الدخول من
بلد اخرى همم محيطه بقطر زي الامارات او
زي مصر او اي دوله خليجيه اخرى
[موسيقى]